[Music]
we are back I'm here with cahier
Suleiman who was the co-founder and CTO
of maluma and who is now a principal
research program manager at Microsoft
and Jonathan cow a research manager at
Microsoft Research Redmond they're going
to talk to us today about literate
machines they will share with us a
little bit about the latest research and
getting machines to read with
comprehension and right like people do
welcome to here and Jen Fang how you
doing
happy to be here great yeah how they
doing here done I'm studies NLP I've
studied machine translation I don't know
what machine reading comrade jizz so why
don't you start out with describing what
it actually is that way we can get a
sense for what it is how DePalma
structure yes so I mean the groups here
at Microsoft
whether it's Melua redmond or Microsoft
Asia we're working on this you know
vision of having neural networks be able
to take in large amounts of unstructured
text and then be able to perform tasks
with it these tasks could be something
like question answering so we want to be
able to really comprehend this the
information is there and you can almost
break down reading comprehension into
these multiple levels of skills
one being reasoning the other being
knowledge representation how do we
represent knowledge about the world how
do we represent knowledge in the text
and then finally extending that beyond
to calming sense
what is how do we know about everyday
things in our lives and you know how do
we then take that from text and do
something useful if I can give you a bit
of history as we over the last 20 years
we have tried that repart large amounts
of test data on web and dictionaries by
identifying entities and their
relationships to create the knowledge
graph as cohere say sure a reason why we
hit a wall in terms of performance by
approaching it this way and do you know
what the missing piece no I mean I
remember doing something for example
like wordnet and and it might look like
an extension of word net that sort of
mapped all these days but I always felt
like how are you going to represent
everything
yeah that's that's one of the key issues
and she actually went off the critical
missing piece is so called a semantic
reasoning for this way if there wasn't
an exact history that matched your idea
you could not find alpha I feel point up
or there are tons of different ways of
saying how long a river is and they
remember there is a key difference
between a similar Wars and similar
concepts that's why we result to neural
networks to relate to thematically
similar concepts and entities by mapping
them into a hidden semantic space where
semantically related the concepts are
paired together so my question is I
understand like I understand how deep
mind would stop working because it's
looking for like regular text and it
doesn't find the exact text or if the
question is phrased in a way it's never
seen it's never going to be able to pull
in a minute meaning but my question to
you is but that model I understand how
to code it right I understand how to how
to work it how how were using deep
learning to represent text without a
task right because generally when we
have text there's like a task I want you
to find I remember the first NLP thing
is we had a bunch of emails for disease
outbreaks and I need to find what the
disease was and what died it was a
specific task but with machine reading
comprehension there's really no task
right well I mean the task okay so if
we're talking about understanding word
meanings
we've create we create this task based
on this idea that words are known their
meeting is told by its neighbors right
so the words that are around it so we
build these models that can predict
words around it so that we can get word
means but there is a task with reading
comprehension okay it's a QA time so how
do we test you know child comprehension
we give them a passage we give them
questions and then we say answer them
based on this passage and that's how
we've been setting up you know tasks for
reading comprehension so that the main
target of the main output of this is we
wanted to consume all this text and we
want to be able to ask it anything about
anything in any particular form is that
and so how does it deal with ambiguous
question like that's the thing I have a
hard time with for example dr. gross was
talking about the hey where are the ten
nearest pharmacies which one is open
right how does it deal with context can
it do that tell me about that work this
has something ridiculous and the hidden
semantic space okay in that space all
the language of different explanations
where we represent using vectors okay in
that hidden space that's the interesting
thing about this space if there's two
cash streams they are semantically
similar then no matter how they are
different from service form new words
stick together in that semantic space
that's magic and so this this network is
literally gluing all of these things
together in a way that we maybe don't
quite understand but seems to work
that's why in most cases the most
effective model is trend by performing
tasks not by remembering things I see I
see and that's a human feature so so
where is this thing they are in this
area right now let's talk about like is
it working so I mean I think the biggest
and most interesting areas that have
seen improvement recently are in the
area of reasoning the ability to use
something called an attention model to
figure out to learn to look where in the
text semantically things are related to
the question be able to combine these
facts that are in the text together also
you know we've made some progress
looking at QA in a different angle as a
generation tasks so where you model not
the model reasoning not from the
retrieval point of view where we just
ask masking answering a question you
look at it from the point of view of how
do we what's the mechanism for
generating the question that led to the
answer call answers so these are kind of
the areas that I think have we've seen
the biggest improvement but of course I
think some of the other areas like
knowledge representation and common
sense they're still work to go what
about you where's the speedy arm for
this ah okay I can give you
example recently we developed a noodle
machine reading comprehension model
called the reason net which has you a
lot of promise the model uses the neural
networks to not only remember things but
learn to perform real-world tasks using
knowledge such as
question answering okay I actually also
we do know exactly how human brain works
but this is a constant source of
inspiration for us when ample resonance
tries to mimic the inference process of
human readers think about this when you
read a document with a question in mind
you always read document several times
each time focusing on different portion
of the document until a satisfy the
answer is formed in your brain a reason
that works just like that but in the
neuro space so I think maybe like I just
barely started understanding neural
networks I understand I remember
learning neural networks but now that
they're there they're a lot deeper they
can do a lot more imprecise I'm trying
to understand how does it encode that
information that's the true su training
plan until we use a large amounts of
question-answer pairs as training it and
to help the reason that you lend the
models give you an example if the plan
for the model you give a model question
the model we're trying to form an answer
to the question by leveraging the useful
information all relevant information
starting this memory but in a case that
such information is missing the memory
then the the real net needs to learn to
seek and store new information by
updating its memory by so called a
reinforcement and landing so that the
network will be able to answer the
question
last time so for training if I'm
understanding this right you give it a
lot of questions it creates a
representation and then you ask it more
questions and more questions than it
updates its representation what does
that representation look like
okay like I'm a pro result one of the
things that that's been there's been
some interesting work is on visualizing
these representations so if you could
almost look at it like the way we have
to look at it as the way we visualize
things going on in the brain we have to
because what it really is is a large
vector space where things certain things
get activated based on certain work
that's what's happening right so you can
look at it like the way people look at
fMRI so and when certain you know when
certain words appear certain neurons get
activated in the neural network just
like what's happening in in the brain
certain regions of the brain get lit up
and not sort of what it really looks
like you know and it could look
different at any different time of the
network I see what do these vectors look
like I mean when I I'm asking a question
like I'm trying to like because I'm a
program right heart right we all are
down when it comes down to it these
steering's are very nice but then we got
to type something into the computer like
when it's coming in what kind of
transformations are you doing and then
how do you actually get the thing to
spit out a reasonable answer because
it's not just a question of getting
information now but then it's got to
write it out in a way like you know
there's so we and what happens is and
jump on can talk more detail about this
is you start off on what we call the
symbolic space which is the words they
get transformed into a set of vectors
these vectors then get transformed over
and over again by the neural network
that's doing a reasoning as it updates
its memory then at the end we transform
it back by making predictions based on
the output at work so we transform it
back to symbolic so now your answer is
in the space that you and I understand
internally you know the they're just
vectors and different regions of this
vector space are going to get activated
when different words come in I see
something
you know the neuro space just like
you're Brian yeah oh you can come up
with an answer to a question I really
don't know how you generally the answer
young Brian let the brain is in the
neural networks that I can neuro space
so usually you take the crashing from
the symbolic space and a map in the
neuro space so in the neuro space that's
where the body's vectors are
you generally the answer in your brain
then you need to speak out this
generally the answer and then by
transforming it from the neuro space to
the somatic space so that people Candice
and I see so you're getting under
getting some some real human input you
put it through this washing machine and
this stuff happens there and then what
it does is it goes backwards out our
washing machine and then it outputs a
really a really good answer
so what are some real-world applications
of your research that you that people
are actually using so one of the areas
that we we were looking at is how do we
take you know the the state-of-the-art
models in machine reading cognition and
how do we put it to use with something
that would say would actually help
people and the first thing and think
that came to our mind was you know in
your car you have that 400 page Auto
manual and you probably have never read
it not yet your car gets in trouble all
that information is there so the idea
was can we ingest large documents like a
health manual user guides etc and then
be able to do QA on this document
I see so next time I can't make my TV
work I just feed the manual or the
computer and I ask the computer okay how
do I make this part of my TV yeah or
where is this in the machine in the TV
or why why is this not happening exactly
I see and I was just a piece of software
that's out in production somewhere I
been development okay I see I see so
this is this is really cool what's next
I think you know the big area as I
mentioned the couple areas with
knowledge representation so while we've
made strides in reasoning but how do we
represent how do we factor reasoning
from knowledge representation so that we
can you know give it any arbitrary
amount of knowledge and the system can
then reason on that and then the other
area that I think is really key is
common sense reasoning which is you know
look people haven't people are you know
are working on it but we haven't really
made any major breakthroughs in this and
there's a bit difficulty with this I'd
say the difficulty is that we are often
working in what we call single modality
where as humans we experience everything
in many many modalities that we have
sight with you know hearing we have text
we have all sorts of stuff and
we just we get common sense you and I by
experiencing it in the world but when we
give it to a you know this computer the
computer can't experience the world and
you know text sometimes is not only
enough to learn it and that's what makes
it really really difficult
I see so there's like a there's a loss
and fidelity and just having things in
text yeah so there could be cries
because and this is because common sense
is assumed right when we write text we
assume through the experience in the
world that the common sense is already
there that ever the reader is already
going to know about it so we just don't
really write that we don't write ok the
ball was up went up in the air the ball
hits the ground because we assume that
you know when you throw a ball up in the
air the laws of physics apply sure
jumping yeah for in what chaos and
that's also the reason why the current
mushroom reading comprehend casks are a
little bit too simple to develop common
sense of reasoning I just give you
example wooden of the day said called
the squad in that day today there the
assumption that given the crashing the
answer must be in the text meaning that
you don't need any common sense reading
if you read the text that you understand
text together it's a simplified setting
which were not encouraged the machine to
learn common sense reading we need a
more comprehensive and charming task in
order for the machine to learn common
sense really and you have worked on it
and you're saying more complex tasks and
just here's a set of questions yeah get
it out of this it really comes down to
you know you can do this with QA but you
really comes down to what you're doing
QA over and what is the reasoning and
skills needed to answer the question if
all I need to do is literally like do
you know search find then the model as
well and that's all I need to do to take
that's in this task then any model that
we train is only going to be as good as
that it can only do fine we need to
build tasks that really make it common
sense reasoning required or make
knowledge represent require make complex
reasoning required so is that the area
because I mean because
first thing I thought is machine reading
comprehension there's tons of
assumptions that I made like for example
when I understand stuff and text I'm
making mental models that I can use
later to do other stuff and learn other
things but the tasks that you're
describing right now seems very narrow
what are some things that we're doing in
order to make it have sort of that
common sense fall and pull that we try
to introduce a concept called a long
term memory into model okay
I think about how people generally our
common sense it's two years years of
experiencing I of the world and then
what you learned in the past cannot be
useful in the future to solve new tasks
but that's the capability is lacking in
the current machine learning and machine
comprehension tasks possible believe it
or not we're out of time I wish we had
tons more time it's always really
interesting Thank You Vera temping for
your insights into machine reading
comprehension